في خدم حرب السيطره على مجلس سيد نواب
والشيوخ في انتخابات التجديد النصفي
المقبله تبرز بنسلفانيا كاحد اكبر ميادين
المعارك بين الحزب الجمهوري والحزب
الديمقراطيطي
في قضيه المناخ وحقوق النساء اريد من
الحزب ان يعمل على رفع الحد الادنى للاجور
[تصفيق]
الماضيه يحاول الاحتفاظ بمكاسبه عبر
استماره الناخبين مستغلا عناوين عده يمكن
ان تلعب دورا مهما في اختياراتهم
المواطنين يهتمون بمصداقيه الانتخابات
العامه والانتشار الكبير
هو امر سيعمل عليه الديمقراطيون اهالي بن
سلمان يهتمون بالاقتصاد ويعلمون ان
الديمقراطيين يعملون مع الجميع
الحزب الازرق هدف هذه المره استماره
الناخبه الجمهوري لصفوفه عبر حمله اعلانات
منسقه تماما كهذه اللوحه في وسط بيتسبرغ
ثاني اكبر مدن الولايات التي تدعو الناخب
الجمهوري لاختيار المرشح الديمقراطي في
الاستحقاق المقبل
[تصفيق]
هناك فقراء واكثر من الاغنياء يصعدون الى
المنصات ويقولون انهم سيساعدون الناس ولكن
ماذا يفعلون حقيقه
الديمقراطيون يكثفون حملاتهم ونشاطاتهم في
المدن وفي بيتسبرغ تحديدا وذلك للخاصيه
التي تمثلها هذه المدينه لكونها شهيده على
العصر الذهبي لصناعه الصلب والمعادن
الامريكيه وتداعيات اصوله على السكان
الذين وجدوا انفسهم عاطلين عن العمل
ومهمشين مع احتلال الحملات الانتخابيه بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين في كنسلفانيا
كونها احدى الولايات الحاسمه في
الانتخابات المقبله تبقى استراتيجيه
الديمقراطيين مواجهه نحو سكان المدن
الاستقطابهم واقناعهم بالتوجه المراكز
الاقتراع في الانتخابات المقبله والتصويت
لصالحها انت سليمان العربيه